pull up aronia cardboard pizza stool
right next to your portable collapsible
solar-powered anywhere fridge because
it's episode 43 of loop or heading out
for the night cover yourself deliciously
with Pizza Cologne but be sure to put on
a wearable safety device in case it
attracts any hungry bad guys
first sign creates headbands and hair
clips that detect movement of an attack
trigger an alarm and then automatically
collect evidence through a microphone
then check your led Meno light a box
that blinks silent color-coded lights to
let you know who's trying to get a hold
of you and how without needing to check
your phone you won't have to check the
weather anymore because the smart cloud
brings the weather to you in the form of
a speaker and light
hopefully it rains enough to plant your
own pencils or at least these pencil
nubs that have hidden seeds inside to
grow your own plants plant yourself in
front of some manga Shakespeare and then
use your manga cookbook to cook yourself
a cat burger bed you've got to be
kidding me right now if a beloved pet
passes away bring them back as a tree
with this biodegradable pet urn which
holds a seed of your choice watch movies
TV and play video games anywhere with
keikar the portable projector that
features 360 degree sound and then
project the time messages and your
facebook status with this projection
watch the Rideau displays a multitude of
applications onto your hand that you can
dismiss with the shake of your wrist and
it's also waterproof or just turn
yourself into an instant unicorn that
comes in this handy 4-pack personally I
don't need a horn to be legendary
because I believe in myself
pillow make others believe your books
are floating with this hanging book rack
or just hang out in your amazing
floating outdoor bed then sit by the
fire and change the colors with some
mystical fire colorings and hold hands
with a loved one online with fredle a
small handheld device that lets you use
Skype FaceTime or their own app to send
touch to people from far away if you
don't have anyone to virtually hold
hands with use a fidget ring to play
alone each different design allows you
to tilt roll and slide parts around to
keep your hands
see if you need that keep your hands and
ears full with dub Stein among that
integrates speakers so you have music
everywhere you put your beverage like
sitting atop this shipping container
coffee table for a drink that's
challenging use this crossword mug and
hopefully you're good with words because
I'm not sure how many problems I have
because math is one of them
the sweatshirt if you have a problem
knowing which end to use this towel
reminds you where to put your book face
after all that my face is going straight
to a pillow because I already want to
take a nap tomorrow and as always thanks
for watching